please pastime all we know the thousand
generations live in you now
but this is your side
on December 20th
this saga
we'll end
[Music]
let us find all that water
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
right now
they fly now
confronting fear
the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
it's okay that we're here it's okay that
you're here's good to see you that to us
our Wars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
this will be the final word
in the story of Skywalker
[Music]
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now and fronting fear it's the
destiny of a Jedi your destiny
[Music]
if this mission fails it was all for
nothing
[Music]
we're not alone good people will fight
if we lead them
[Music]
yes it's in Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker tickets available now
oh we've done all this time we're doing
there's repeal taking one last look sir
my friend
[Music]
confronting fear
the destiny of the Jedi
your destiny
we're all in this
the land and star wars the rise of
Skywalker tickets available now
[Music]
confronting fear
is the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
the force will be with you always
[Applause]
tickets available now
you